the former President Bill Clinton is
tackling fictional terrorism in a new
novel he co-authored the book with
best-selling writer James Patterson the
president is missing follows a rogue
commander-in-chief who fights
international terrorists after a cyber
attack in the u.s. mr. Clinton spoke
about it with Mo Rocca for CBS Sunday
morning he also addressed Russia's
meddling in the 2016 election and why
cyber terror is a real threat here's a
preview and we got a real serious
problem with this cyber terrorism they
could go way beyond fixing the elections
and those problems will happen faster if
we allow our elections to continue to be
tampered with powders do you think there
was any tampering in 2016 with results I
don't know I don't know
President Clinton also discusses his
impeachment and response for the first
time to senator Kirsten Gillibrand
remark that he should have resigned over
his affair with Monica Lewinsky see it
all this weekend on CBS Sunday morning
my eyes are popping out of my head mine
too that is a very good tease that is
know the answer to that question John
what is it
which one about the election oh yes
whether Christian but also his position
it sounds like on the election and
whether the Russian meddling affected it
seems slightly different than his wife's
position
[Music]